there's very clearly different states
and then we have states with Sanctuary
City policies and Sanctuary State
policies to where they won't even
extradite criminals to other states and
so how are we a cohesive United States
the only thing that we're not together
is that we have a large federal
government which is which is kind of the
antithesis of the 10th Amendment yes so
we are not a coach we are not what we
were anymore we are definitely
separating and this I think the way
forward is with strong states rights
I've always said this like we're not how
to have a national divorce we're going
to have strong states rights so we're
these 50 states are going to look like
50 different countries is is my idea of
it like Florida is going to get more
Florida California is going to get more
California New York's going to get more
New York because of the voting policies
in these states that are not going to
allow really any any difference you know
especially in the blue states where
anybody can vote and stuff but what we
have to do is then shrink the size of
the federal government to create the
better absolutely we worry about the
supremacy clause when it comes to some
of the powers that they have as opposed
to the 10th Amendment